[Musique]
oui où
où
[Musique]
l'analyse de cette semaine est très
sympa déjà à jouer lundi deux fois
trente minutes face à jeu aux jeunes à
11 juillet deux fois trente minutes face
au gel d'art avec un groupe diminué
puisque j'ai des joueurs qui n'étaient
pas présentes sur la compétition est
derrière nous dans la complexité
je le dis quand même hans kung fu
j'arrive ici le match à 18 heures j'ai
un groupe qui arrive est 17h et le
groupe tient à 17h30 à 17h35
voilà mon début de match quoi ouais mon
deuxième groupe a été pris dans un
embouteillage alors bon début de match a
été très poussif
d'où le fait qu'il ya eu 7 but de
concentrer et derrière on revient mais
le début de match il était fatal
[Musique]
ouais bilan très positif quand même on a
mené on a mené tout le match sur la fin
je joue quasiment une autonomie elle
trouve des solutions
on a couru une gardienne aussi qui nous
sont un bon match voilà donc je pense
que tout a été sur cette rencontre là
[Musique]
analysera bourassa les anciennes les
airs face parce qu'il faut savoir qu'il
ya pas mal d'anciennes dans l'équipe de
l'indre évident les anciennes ont su
encore une fois augmenter leur niveau de
jeu et derrière il ya des tidjanes au
fur et à mesure de la compétition elles
ont pris un peu d'initiatives et de
poings coups de bouteille comme on dit
dans le jargon
et moi mon analyse ont bien ma
satisfaction sur la compétition en
attendant parce qu'elle n'est pas fini
il y aura ce samedi le plus jeune on
voit loubette un petit mauvais comment
elles se sont un peu lâchés alors
j'espère que samedi elles vont
réellement se lâcher le dernier match de
la saison pour que ça soit pas
performant ou satisfaisant pas aux
titres quoi bein l'objectif c'est de
jouer l'année à fond même si on sait que
c'est une très très grosse équipe
l'un portant sur ces compétitions la
ciutat c'est de ne pas avoir de regrets
qu'on va jouer à fond
après on sait que voilà que ça reste m
on va jouer à fond ça leur permet quand
même de toucher à ça et pas une
progression quoi l'année dernière sont
aussi champions de n3 l'aide championne
tram arrêt derrière offert une finale
henin pour un groupe de jeunes garmin
comme ça chapeau
[Musique]
à
ah ah
[Musique]